46 the stair climbing challenge for
charity scale of strat it's back this
weekend it's the largest fundraiser to
support the american lung association
yeah this is really beautiful they're on
track to raise more than 200 thousand
dollars in the fight against lung
disease which affects a lot of folks
here in southern nevada we've got hector
mejia out there live this morning uh
hector talk about their mission but boy
what a beautiful look behind you you
already scaled the strap wow
yeah well isn't the view gorgeous and i
am proud to say i scaled the strat this
morning with the help of an elevator but
you know who will not be using an
elevator this weekend pete here who's
going to talk to us not only about how
can you prepare if you want to do it too
but also why do you do it good morning
good morning so i scale the strat this
will be year 12 for me so super excited
to be back at the strat it's 108 stories
455 steps
so i climb for my mom
my mom had copd she had recently passed
and i always think about how she
struggled
you know just to breathe day in and day
out so the cool thing about the climb is
when you start hitting these
higher flights you will be out of breath
so on that note how can you even prepare
for this it's more than just going a
couple of steps yeah it sure is so
obviously running conditioning i think
doing bleachers
and taking stairs at work instead of
using the elevator is a great way to get
ready for this event
tell us about the overall mission this
is really helping uh
with those efforts and really crucial
battle here yeah so this is our big tent
pole fundraising event we are right now
over two hundred thousand dollars um
that we put together for the american
lung association that helps her advocacy
for research and for programs here in
nevada and lastly i bet you are glad
it's coming back to the strat the iconic
original location yeah super excited
like i said i've done it 12 years and
you know getting to the top of this is
unlike any other event that they do and
i mean look at this
look at it
awesome pete thank you very much for
your insight and for joining us this
early in the morning so registration is
already closed online however it's open
in person we'll talk a little bit more
about that still ahead at six o'clock
for now reporting live hector mejia live
local now back to you guys thank you so
much hector that means i could still
change my mind and do it this year